Hello again, Dr. Cutters with section 18, this video is shorter because it's what we really spoke about in the previous three sections
Because in this section you're going to read about different immune modulators to bring that immune system back into balance
Now there's a difference between an immune stimulator and an immune modulator just so you know
It's not important for you to know, but this gives you a list at least a different things that will help bring that
balance of your immune system back
And one of the things that we talked about in this is medicine a mushroom used as an immune modulator. So it's
It's very good. Many of the medicinal mushrooms are
used as modulators of your hormone system as well. They are what are called
adaptogens
And adaptogen helps bring your immune system into balance whether you have a hyper
Adrenal situation like an asympathetic response or a hypo in a parasympathetic response
Cordyceps especially is a wonderful adaptogen. That's a meta. That's a medicine a mushroom that works so well for that
Again, one of the reasons why I'm so high in medicinal mushrooms. They just work well in somebody's situations
Whether it's cancer or just to help prevent cancer or immune system
Disregulation and autoimmune dysfunction. It's just a great great supplement
So enough said about that. Read about this. You'll learn a lot and I will see you soon